it's like throwing darts 100 times
better because it's axe and its original
nobody did that before
well because sometimes when you're
drinking you get queasy and sometimes
you get goofy and we don't need an
accident we don't think
there are more girls actually they're
interested in testing this activity I
feel like in Quebec were very daring and
this types of activity are kind of fun
to do
friends and most of us go out with our
girlfriends so it's a fun activity to do
with our friends
it requires spraying the next arity and
I think it's you know that's what's
challenging you abyss but not everyone
can everyone can do it but not
everyone's gonna be good at it at first
which is really nice you have to think
about you know the way you're trying in
when you shoot I don't think you're that
you guys you have that much muscle being
actually requests to do it when archery
actually hold it hold it which I would
think it's more I think it's more
replacing the archery than the firearms